va nuevamente por dar un Street el ex
encargado de economía anunció que
buscará liderazgo del partido
conservador y el rol del Primer Ministro
tras perder ante listras en las
consultas internas hace dos meses Reino
Unido es un gran país pero enfrentamos
una profunda crisis económica es por eso
que buscaré ser líder del partido
conservador y su próximo Primer Ministro
quiero arreglar nuestra economía voy a
ir a nuestro partido y cumplirle a
nuestro país según la bbc sunac es el
más respaldado por el partido con casi
150 pollos de parlamentarios
conservadores lo siguen Boris Johnson
con 57 y Penny morton con 24 según las
reglas establecidas por el comité de
1922 después de la renuncia detrás quien
aspira reemplazarla debe contar con por
lo menos 100 respaldos
tras el anuncio es una la oposición
reiteró su disconformidad con el momento
político y la continuidad del gobierno
pagando un precio muy muy alto por este
caos continuo en el partido conservador
y ya sea Boris Johnson o cualquiera de
los otros contendientes son pirómanos
tratando de apagar el fuego que ellos
mismos iniciaron No necesitamos un
cambio de Primer Ministro necesitamos un
cambio de gobierno
aún no ha oficializado sus intenciones
pero su regreso tras interrumpir sus
vacaciones en el Caribe es un indicio de
que podría buscar una revancha en el
poder
mordon quien fue la primera en Elevar su
candidatura parece tener chances remotas
lo que este país necesita es una cara
nueva alguien que pueda unir al partido
conservador Y hacer que las cosas
funcionen ocupado 9 cargos ministeriales
tres en el gabinete pero más importante
que todo eso es que tengo experiencia de
la vida real sé lo que la gente está
pasando en este momento porque he estado
allí
el lunes vence el plazo para enlistarse
en la carrera por ser el quinto Premier
del Reino Unido en solamente seis años